(audience screaming)
- [Lea] You guys just--
- [Lea] I was backstage!
- Here's what's great,
it's the first season, Lea.
- So we don't have any money.
- Oh my gosh!
- So apparently we can only
snow in certain places,
and they're getting dumped on!
- I saw! It was so funny
because I have a funny story,
when I was on Glee, I
did a song from Frozen.
And we had the fake snow,
and it was like really heavy.
And I looked up during
the song, being like,
"Wow, this is a lot of snow,"
and choked on the fake snow.
- No, that's actually happened to me.
- In the middle of the performance.
And then it got really messy
and we were filming in slo-mo
and they got the entire thing on camera.
- Oh!
- If you know what I mean.
- So, my sympathies just--
- That's awesome.
- This is a lot.
Anyways.
- That's actually funny,
I have choked on fake snow
in a performance before.
This must be a thing for singers.
- You gotta be careful.
- You gotta get it out of the mouth.
- Just zip it.